isabelle morini bosc bien sûr dans tpm p
c'est un personnage phare regardez
petite compil d'isabelle morini bosc et
juste après on va voir si elle va faire
un strike c'est une petite surprise pour
elle on vous dirais tu as du temps parce
que c'est vrai mine de rien c'est le
magazine ne plus tirer
et oui puisque nettement plus que moi ça
c'est sûr
au fait les lacanienne pour danser tati
et les règles
voilà qu'est ce qu'il ya j'ai
l'impression d'être avec matin
[Musique]
je
gervais
je me
j'en fais
je vais monter
même
[Musique]
il bosse nous avouer qu'elle ne prenait
pas de douche et bien on a décidé de
s'occuper d'elle
[Musique]
maintenant
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui moi joe
[Musique]
déjà des bruits gauche
[Applaudissements]